what do you think the main focus for men  should be for overall health a high  quality sleep for sure I think a lot of  people are burning the candle at both  ends and either their circadian rhythm  is out of whack they are you know not  getting to bed at an adequate time and  then also not following a regular  schedule and then even when they're  doing that they're sleep even if it's  eight hours it's oftentimes segmented or  not like high quality enough to actually  break the rewards out of it that they  could otherwise be getting and that's  massively impactful on many different  hormone systems most notable how  detrimental it is the testosterone  levels in men because that's the only  like restorative time of the day where  your body can actually deal with you  know cancer cell proliferation recovery  from your workouts also mental health  massively impacted by quality of sleep  for sure so I would say that's like the  biggest thing